a bunch of fantastic games are hitting
PlayStation Plus I'm Lucy and here's
your October PlayStation Plus Rundown
[Music]
let's kick things off with the monthly
games which are available on PlayStation
Plus essential extra and premium
first up is Hot Wheels Unleashed for PS4
and PS5 a game that combines the thrill
of fast-paced racing with the joy of
collecting all your favorite Hot Wheels
Vehicles alongside that is Injustice 2
for PS4 a fighting game that's got a
whole lot more to it than just throwing
punches play as some of your favorite DC
heroes and villains through a multi-hour
campaign where they're clashing ideals
of the Justice League members have
turned friends into enemies and the fate
of the world hangs in the balance
super hot the PS4 is your last
PlayStation monthly game for October
super hot is a stylish mind-bending
first person shooter slash Puzzler where
time only moves when you do since its
launch in 2016 it's been lauded as being
one of the most distinct and memorable
games around and it's easy to see why
if you're a PlayStation Plus extra or
premium member you also get access to
the game catalog and this month it's
getting loads of new titles added to it
it's spooky season so why not get your
creep on with inside or the medium which
are both in the game catalog inside is a
puzzle platformer that has a lingering
sense of dread and an incredible ending
that will stick with you long after
you've put the controller down the
medium is a psychological horror that
takes place in not one reality but two
playing as a medium you can slip between
the real world and the spirit world to
escape the terrifying more and get to
the bottom of a devastating mystery if
all that sounds too spooky then the
soothing sounds of hohokum will ease
that stress explore colorful world and
uncover Secrets all while listening to a
gorgeous calming soundtrack next up is
Grand Theft Auto Vice City the
definitive edition for PS4 and PS5 this
remake of a stone cold classic features
quality of life and visual upgrades but
at its heart is still Tony versetti's
incredible story wacky Life Of Crime
hijinks and a banger of a soundtrack
if you've never dipped your toes into
the world of Dragon Quest then now is
the time five Dragon Quest games are
also joining the game catalog and you're
bound to find one you like if you're a
fan of building games like Minecraft and
Terraria then have a go on Dragon Quest
Builders and its sequel Dragon Quest
Builders 2 for PS4 both games feature
combat and a fun story but the real Joy
is in gathering materials and building
there's nothing quite like the thrill
that comes from creating something from
scratch if you fancy a more traditional
jrpg Dragon Quest 11s Echoes of an
elusive aged definitive edition for PS4
could be your cup of tea as the luminary
it's up to you and your ragtag group of
companions to defeat the dark Forces who
threaten the land this Definitive
Edition also comes with a bunch of
extras like the Japanese voice track a
new version of the soundtrack and an
option to toggle between 2D and 3D
graphic modes or if you're in the mood
for some hack and slash fun then Dragon
Quest Heroes the world trees woe and the
blight below and Dragon Quest Heroes 2
Explorer's Edition for the PS4 are
perfect for some action in an Akira
Toriyama inspired world
those looking to live the life of a
Ninja can team up with friends online
and give Naruto to boruto Shinobi
Striker for PS4 ago form squads of up to
four players and battle online against
others to find out just who the best
Shinobi are all your favorite characters
from the boruto's dad spin-off series
are there to pick from a bunch of
Assassin's Creed games are also
available on the game catalog from
sprawling open world RPGs to tighter
more linear experiences starting with my
personal favorite and not just because
it's set in London Assassin's Creed
Syndicate take control of Assassins
Jacob and Evie fry as they fight to take
the boroughs of London back from the
Templar gangs taking over there's also
Assassin's Creed 3 remastered the first
Mainline Assassin's Creed after Ezio's
Saga came to a close taking place in
18th century America AC3 introduced a
new protagonist more fluid parkour Naval
Combat and new weapons like the Rope
Dart Assassin's Creed Odyssey is a fan
favorite and if you've not played it or
are itching to play as alexios or
Cassandra once again now's your chance
as it's also coming to game catalog
Odyssey takes place in ancient Greece
during the Peloponnesian War Between
Athens and Sparta and has more of a
focus on combat than stealth as a
mercenary you fight on both sides but
also hunt down and destroy the evil Cult
of Cosmos all the Assassin's Creed
Chronicles titles are also joining the
catalog so you can join the fight
against the Templars in China India and
Russia the Chronicles games are
side-scrolling Platformers but don't
worry the core tenets of stealth combat
and parkour still play a huge role
if you're a PlayStation Plus premium
subscriber you also get access to the
classics catalog and lucky you because
Yakuza 3 4 and 5 remastered or all
joining the catalog this month if you've
watched this PS Plus update series
before or follow me on Twitter you know
how much I love the Yakuza games they're
a perfect mix of melodrama and absurdity
so consider this my plea to you to have
a go Yakuza zero kawami and kiwami 2 are
already in the game catalog so dig in to
one of the best gaming sagas around but
that's not all that's joining the roster
as there are also some PS3 games to
round out the month's offerings like
limbo which is made by the same team who
made inside it's another Moody and
Atmospheric platformer and it won't
surprise you to learn that inside is
considered a spiritual sequel to limbo
while you're getting excited for Street
Fighter 6 why not indulge yourself in
some Ultra Street Fighter 4 for PS3 it
shares some mechanics with Street
Fighter 6 so it's good for getting those
fighting game muscle warmed up there's
also everyday shooter which is a unique
take on Shooters and finally Castlevania
Lords of Shadow a 3D take on konami's
beloved vampire hunting franchise
so if you're watching and wondering well
what's the difference between all the
plans and how can I make sure I've got
access to all these amazing games don't
worry I've got you covered let's start
with PlayStation Plus essential for 9.99
per month or 59.99 for the year you get
access to a bunch of benefits like
online multiplayer exclusive store
discounts exclusive content cloud
storage for your saves and share play an
online service that lets your friends
play with you even if they don't own the
game but the big benefit of PlayStation
Plus essential is free monthly games
that are yours to keep as long as you
have an active subscription if you have
a PlayStation 5 you get extra goodies
like access to the PlayStation Plus
collection a curated library of some of
the best PlayStation games and game help
a service that offers tips and
walkthroughs on select games if you were
previously subscribed to PlayStation
Plus and didn't change your membership
you'll have been automatically enrolled
into this plan if you subscribe to
PlayStation Plus extra you get all the
benefits of the essential plan and more
you get access to the game catalog a
library of hundreds of PS4 and PS5 games
that you can download and enjoy from
Indie Darlings and hidden gems to
family-friendly hits and bombastic
Blockbusters there's something for
everyone you also get the Ubisoft plus
Classics Library which is filled with
your favorite Ubisoft hits from
franchises like Assassin's Creed and Far
Cry PlayStation Plus extra is 14.99 per
month or 99.99 for the year PlayStation
Plus premium includes everything from
essential and extra and includes other
benefits like game Trials which lets you
try out games before you buy if you do
get the full game after your trial your
progress and any trophies you earned
will carry over premium members also get
access to the classics catalog which
features incredible titles from previous
PlayStation consoles if that's not
enough premium members can also stream
games to PC and progress syncs across
the two PlayStation Plus premium costs
17.99 a month or
199.99 for the year what are you going
to be playing on PlayStation Plus this
month let us know and make sure to shout
out your hidden gems below you can find
me on Twitter at Lucy James games and
I'll see you next month for your
November games
[Music]